alright so sneaky is done playing League
of Legends professionally at least for
now so what's next for league's most
popular cosplayer well maybe he could be
the next round
maybe alright so back when everyone was
losing their minds about League of
Legends offseason roster moves a lot of
people had one pretty simple question
what's gonna happen to sneak I would
just say that at this point in time I'd
be surprised if he starts week 1 of LCS
if you don't know who sneaky is he's
probably one of the three or four most
popular League of Legends players in
North America he's played in almost
every single split of the league he was
a superstar ad carry from one of North
America's most popular teams for like
seven years and well he's really good at
cosplay seriously this is impressive
whoever does his makeup is amazing
anyway while players like hooni Brasa
and spend scare and we're making
headlines during the off-season
guys like sneaky were sort of left out
in the cold notably people were upset
that guys like pobelter
a veteran talent and Demonte a promising
young rookie didn't get a starting spot
on any of the LCS rosters meanwhile
sneaky was still signed to cloud 9 but
they already had an ad carry now he said
he wanted to keep playing pro but also
that he didn't want to have to fight for
a starting spot on the roster basically
nobody even knew what was going on with
him
sneaky didn't really give any updates
about his situation over the holidays
and by the time the offseason basically
wrapped up we really didn't know
anything people expected some kind of
update but he just kept on streaming
oh my god it's so nasty
it's so [ __ ] gross and then on
Wednesday literally as I was leaving the
office Sneaky announced that he was
taking a break from fro play and was
gonna focus on full-time streaming
according to the statement that Sneaky
posted on Twitter he was basically
shopping himself around to various LCS
teams with the help of c9 owner jackets
yen but he didn't find any teams that
excited him whatever that means and
honestly I get it early on Sneaky said
he didn't want to have to fight for a
starting spot on a roster so either he
didn't find one or the only starting
spot so left where four teams didn't
mesh with or somebody couldn't pay the
buyout for a team he wanted to be on I
was gonna say I wonder yeah there could
be the bio element too but I wonder how
much of it is his own asking price right
so if he's kind of getting bought out
and then this contract is you know a
little too heavy first it seems with
different operating budgets like you
know we can talk about like every team
having a certain amount of money and
maybe his price was just too high when
there's a lot of reasons he may not have
signed with the team and it's
understandable why he chose this as his
best option and honestly I get it sneaky
said he wanted to keep playing but he
didn't want to have to fight for a
starting spot on a roster so either he
couldn't find that starting spot or he
found starting spots with teams he
didn't mesh with or he was just getting
offers from teams that couldn't buy out
his contract it's understandable that
streaming was the best option at least
for now people are looking at the face
value of sneaky himself when I think if
you're a GM you're not just thinking of
sneaky you're also thinking of the cost
of acquiring his contract as you're
making this decision and maybe write it
and all these places don't care about
that and maybe they actually do care
about it but they're saying well you
should pay millions of dollars to
acquire sneaky but I think that's a
factor that I think a lot of people
should be considering because I cannot
imagine that jack is going out to market
was think he's contract for less than a
million look I don't want to sit here
speculating too much the fact that
matter is sneaky is not playing in this
split of the LCS he might be back one
day he says he still has the competitive
drive and he may return to playing pro
but for now he is focusing on
full-time streaming so what's next well
sneaky says he'll be an independent
streamer which I guess means he won't
have a sponsorship from cloud9 or
anything though confusingly it sneaky
will still be a part owner of c9 and
will work for them and in an advisory
role
he says that'll involve showing up to
events and stuff like that look I'm not
exactly sure what all that means but I
think it has something to do with how c9
was recently fine for paying players at
least partially with shares in c9 anyway
sneaky is already popular as a streamer
and again that cosplay thing is pretty
big for him he's already pulling in a
decent chunk of change from patreon and
who knows maybe that'll even increase
with the move to full-time content
creation now sneaky isn't actually the
first c9 player to do all this obviously
he's the first league of Legends player
to make the jump to full-time streaming
but if you'll remember shroud was
actually a c9 csgo player all those
years ago these days the shroud is one
of the biggest streamers out there and
signed a huge deal with mixer last year
you've got to imagine that sneaky thinks
that that kind of retirement plan is at
least a possibility for him and honestly
who wouldn't be angling for that
something it moves and he may take you
oh hi Benji
now the big difference is that when he
retired Shroud pretty publicly said that
he was done playing pro meanwhile sneaky
has definitively said that he's still
interested in pro play and he may even
return next split or next season but if
he doesn't come back this could be the
end of an era
he was the last remaining member of the
c9 roster that took the LCS by storm all
those years ago this is a guy that's
played league of legends professionally
for seven years and paid the world
championships seven times if he doesn't
come back it's a huge deal
I guess League is life for me I play a
competitively I play it for fun and it's
you know what keeps me going I have to
imagine sneaky fans are pretty
heartbroken right now but if I can give
you guys any hopes all you have to do is
think about hi because he was another c9
player who tries to retire but kept
getting pulled back in when he was
trying to get out
Garen for free it's like say your
favorite ice cream flavor is the cone or
it get or it is a good choice
galio is a good choice there are good
choices and bad choices
Garen
never change seven
[Music]